OK, then, let's get started.
First, let me review the agenda for today's meeting. It's the one I sent out in my e-mail last week.
The purpose of the meeting is to introduce our companies formally...
...and to explore whether a cooperative marketing and sales effort makes sense.
First, Taka will provide an overview presentation introducing Tokyo Technology. Correct?
Yes, that's right.
After Taka's presentation, Victoria will present a similar summary of Silicon Valley Software.
Then, we will discuss our respective marketing and sales strategies...
...to see how we might work together in the future.
Would it be appropriate for us to compare our client and prospect lists?
Did everyone sign the Non-Disclosure Agreement?
Yes, both companies signed the "NDA" so we should definitely cover that.
Thanks, that is a valuable addition to the agenda.
Finally, we will agree on next steps... specific action items for both companies.
That sounds good.
Excellent. Taka, the floor is yours!